these words is full of crazy shady
stories but I think I've had a pretty
wild one for you today it's a story of a
streamer who made up a donation goal
just to scam his fans and all the insane
stuff that happened after he got caught
we've got allegedly stolen donations a
streamer who knows shows for tournaments
forged uber receipts and an imaginary
date this [ __ ] is crazy all right look I
know when you guys see me on camera
you're expecting some serious [ __ ] like
lawsuits or racism or sexual assault but
I can have fun too it's not just Devin
who gets the funny stories okay
[ __ ] swear to God and this is my
favorite weird twist story of the last
little while so if you don't follow
fighting game streamers really closely
you probably haven't heard of Tom Brady
okay you've probably heard of that Tom
Brady but not this Tom Brady this is
Bill Tom Brady minutest a guy whose
dream thought of MORTAL KOMBAT on Twitch
he also occasionally takes donations
from his fans to get him out to
tournaments across North America in the
fighting community this is something
that's relatively common you know there
are streamers particularly in the smash
scene who get donations go to events but
also just all over the place people like
to raise money in the FTC to see their
players compete in tournaments that they
wouldn't otherwise be able to afford to
go to and Tom Brady actually used to
compete a lot more I think he's one stop
ADA Devo in dead or alive fact the
matter is there's a lot of his fans out
there who would want to see him compete
again something he has been unable to do
because he says he's been taking classes
and a lot of his money has been tied up
in that anyway in the lead-up to NEC
2019 Brady opened up donations on his
stream to get him to the event and he
raised about $600 and then the
tournament happened and allegedly he
wasn't there but he's not here he's here
but he's not here it's complicated see
because he made a big deal about how he
was gonna be there there are plenty of
people on the lookout for a Tom Brady
and then no one saw him he even got
disqualified from the Mortal Kombat
bracket because he didn't show up for
his matches so seems pretty cut and dry
right takes the money doesn't show up to
the tournament he scammed people easy
well this is where the story gets in
same people got mad at Brady and started
demanding that he refund their donations
but the problem is that Brady said he
already spent all the money where's my
money [ __ ]
according to Brady on Twitter he didn't
pocket a dime of the donations at this
point in his story and it's gonna change
a couple times so for whatever it's
worth he said he was in Philadelphia he
paid for his hotel at least one night of
it he played for his venue fee he just
didn't show up to the tournament even
though he was there basically Brady said
that his ride to Philly fell through he
was just getting back on a plane from
his Thanksgiving dinner with his family
in Newark he was in Virginia and it just
all didn't work out so he had to take a
train and then that made the uber really
expensive from the train station to the
venue and this is where this all falls
apart for me anyway Brady got on stream
and started telling the story about how
you know that uber was super expensive
and you know wasn't gonna make sense for
him so he didn't go to any seat so he
wasn't in Philly but he did already
spend all the money I guess also he said
on stream that during his flight back
from his Thanksgiving dinner with his
family
the airline who lost his luggage and his
ps4 was in it and oh he so just so
happened to buy this shiny new ps4 but
it was a total coincidence he promises
you want me to return the ps4 Pig is
that gonna make you feel better you want
to return this ps4 and wait a couple
days for the bit that story sounds super
fake and he started to talk about other
things there was like a greyhound and
then the airline disappeared for a
minute and there's an Amtrak train and
I'm gonna be real none of this lined up
like at all it was all shady as hell and
I'm not the only person who thought it
was Shady
lots of people began asking for proof
proof that he was in Philly and then
wasn't in Philly that he had spent the
money that he hasn't spent the money
just proof that Tom Brady was literally
doing anything that weekend other than
scamming people and then suddenly during
this dream another mortal kombat player
piga the hut hosted what appeared to be
receipts that he'd got from tom brady
for an uber ride that he took to the
weekend of the tournament that proved
that he was in Philly at the time of the
event I guess this is all [ __ ] but
that's as far as I understood it the
issue is that the receipt didn't prove
that because the receipt was
photoshopped very very badly
like look at this thing how could you
ever believe it was real let alone the
fact that the font is completely wrong
and there's like JPEG artifacts
everywhere Thursday November 30th isn't
a real date November 30th was a Saturday
what the [ __ ] dude can't you just look
at a calendar every time someone calls
and request a meeting with you
I always schedule it for March 31st why
because I didn't think March 31st
existed so yeah he forged an uber
receipt so at this point we're basically
like two and a half hours into this
stream that was supposed to prove
Brady's innocence and he's only dug his
grave deeper and at this point is when
sonic Hawks mortal kombat champion and
generally fgc good person shows up to
just go in on Brady so stop right here
right you're perfect right just discount
that you have up here perfect here right
so you said in the weeks that I was
asking you where you were you were
saying that entire week you're in New
Jersey are you seeing the problem here
with the stuff that you sent pick of the
hut when you said on November 30th
Thursday that you were in New Jersey
these are you seeing the issue okay so
what you're saying is you want on
Thursday you want to know where I want
issue during this time period here no I
want to know where you were on November
30th Thursday so find the 30th on a
Thursday I see the T so wherever you got
that date from from pick of the hut it
should be no problem for you to be send
that where you got that receipt and sent
the dates to all of us on stream right
now issued november 3 november 30th or
thursday no issue we can send that but
you send it to us but a big deal right
just show me never see ended up like all
right all right I was wrong but until
you show me November 30th on a Thursday
that you were receipt you're full of
[ __ ]
you're actually full of say sonic
eviscerated Rainey for basically 30
minutes and actually got ready to open
up a receipt from December 2nd that just
so happened to perfectly match the
location and price of his receipt from
the alleged Thursday November 30th that
I will remind you doesn't exist
so basically sonic operating to prove on
stream that Brady got an uber
that day photoshopped the receipt and
then sent it to people in order to prove
something I guess and eventually after
sonic left the call and it was all Brady
by himself
Brady admitted that he bucked it all up
I wasn't there people wanted to see me
there I wasn't there you know there are
those they're gonna want their money
back and they deserve it
sonic Fox caught Brady red-handed but
Brady was still there pleading his
innocence he said that he had to force
the receipt because otherwise nobody
would believe him I mean the bottom line
is I had the itinerary for my trip I had
the uber take it back but I was like
[ __ ] I don't have the uber receipt on
the way there so I said well this is not
gonna be enough and no matter what I
show them they're gonna say well if you
don't have this - it's all nothing so I
said I'm just gonna try to change the
data on one of them and that's what I
did though that's insane and eventually
after sonic had left the call and it was
just Brady by himself with his Chad
Brady admitted that he [ __ ] up he
forged the receipt he wasn't at NEC
he wasn't in Philly and you know the
money's gone dad it's God this whole
[ __ ] thing is insane but the best
part is that when Brady opened his email
to show Sonic Fox to receive he actually
showed his most recent email which were
also receipts but for Adobe Acrobat Pro
a piece of software that allowed him to
forge an uber receipt by altering the
PDF now the thing is those receipts were
dated for during the stream that's right
he bought Adobe - forged at ubirr
receipt while he was on street
presumably he was hoping it would all
work out for him but spoilers it didn't
because again Thursday November 30th
didn't exist this year the whole reason
people even caught on to this whole
thing is because allegedly Brady has
done this before it was just this time
it was more high-profile because people
were sick of his [ __ ] and again it was
easier to find out because he sucks at
forging receipts going on Twitter and
reddit right now it feels like everyone
is coming out of the woodwork with their
own stories about how Brady scammed them
at one point or another even dude who
Rio did the footage of Brady stream said
that he at one point was involved with
Brady and making a twist channel
together and Brady scammed him out of
all of the monies but to lighten the
mood
members of the FCC started photoshopping
him into pictures of NEC and then
eventually other pictures too because if
this dude is gonna suck ass to an entire
community at least the community can do
is clown on him right back yeah we
should do an enema what sir I mean we
can just RM board an RN board shouldn't
just be s talking on board okay here's
here's my question for you Keith here's
my question for you know we can do it
guys but here's my question for you
there's a very simple question if you're
forging an uber receipt okay and you're
like all right it's got to be during the
tournament that's November 30th that's
easy
tournaments only happened Friday
Saturday Sunday what possesses you to
make it Thursday and again and it wasn't
Thursday when he got the receipt the
receipt he got on London